where do you stand on like Intuition or
like the supernatural superstitious kind
of things I'm a little bit of a believer
in this sense so when I was a kid when I
was a baby I was born 8 and2 lb for some
reason I started losing a lot of weight
like I got down to like 3 and half lb or
four or something like that like my
stomach wasn't really formed they
thought I was going to die long story
short the priest came and blessed me and
thought I was going to die my dad took
me out of the hospital took me to like
this bruha like it's like a wish doctor
out by um inada and she like whipped up
some with goats milk and seaweed
and Kelvin and said he put this in
his thing and uh feed him back up and
not that works but he'll be on AIS
Hollywood yeah that well I survived
you get